let's think about what it means to add
numbers
so let's start with one
one
plus
one plus one
what is this going to be equal to
one way to think about this
is we have one thing and i will
that thing will be a purple circle so
let me
put that here so that's this one thing
i'm just going to represent with a
purple circle and i'm going to add
another one thing and since this is in
blue i'll make that other circle i'll
make that in blue as well
so let me put that right over here
so one plus one one plus one how many
total circles do i now have
well i now have two circles
i now have two
circles one plus one
is equal to
is equal to two
okay you're saying all right sal
that that makes sense let's do this with
larger numbers so let's say
we want to know what equals and i'll put
a question mark over here so question
mark
what equals
so something
is
equal to
is equal to
let's say
plus 3.
something is equal to 2
what is this something going to be
and i encourage you to pause the video
and think about it on your own
well you could view this as i have two
objects and i'm going to add another
three objects how many total objects
would i have so you have your
two objects which i'll use purple
circles again so let me
let me so we have one
and two purple circles this is the two
right over here and then to that we're
gonna add three more
three more circles and i'll represent
those in blue because we wrote the three
here in blue
so
that is one
two
and three
so how many total circles do we now have
well we could count them we have one
two three four five in fact let me count
that one
two
three
four
five circles so two plus three two
things plus another three things are
five things so our question mark right
over here is equal to five
so instead of writing the question mark
right over here
let me clear that out i could say five
is equal to
i could write down that 5
plus 3.